something very profound is happening
in the way in which we modern people
process information i don't know how
many of you are familiar with marshall
mcluhan but mcluhan argued
that an equally profound transition
occurred
with the introduction of print print is
not simply
writing that's easy to read and
reproduce
print is an entirely different creature
than anything that had been produced
before
it has qualities
that no other medium has specifically
its linearity
its uniformity its interchangeability
and what i mean by that is that
every a every capital a looks like every
other capital a
they are interchangeable when you
when a friend of yours writes you a note
you look at it that's the precondition
to reading it
when you open a book you immediately
read it
you don't look at it at all very few
people puzzle
over how the a is sitting there on the
page with that white back
no we just read and
and the difference between looking and
reading
is very great he mcluhan called it the
contrast between
a manuscript culture which is ear
oriented and an eye-oriented visual
culture
well now what's happening to us is
the rise of the image the image
is in the ascendant ever since the
invention of photography
let's say in the middle 19th century
followed by color
photography followed by color
followed by moving pictures followed by
television
followed by the internet vr and all the
rest of it
something is happening we are our
culture is forcing
our visual education and i think
one of the problems with education is
that we are
trying to use a print-created
institution
to educate uh electronically biased
human beings
and it's created a kind of a speed bump
of illiteracy one of the things that is
put
against your generation you generation
x-series here is that you're not
literary you're not a literary culture
but i and it's true don't deny it none
of you can
quote milton uh but
but i also think it's a temporary thing
your children will not be like you
your children will be fully
visually literate they will have
assimilated this new medium and operate
under its aegis while you are in a
transition phase
and so the the kind of dumbing down of
culture
that has had to occur as we go from a
fully
literate culture to a fully electronic
culture is i think transitional i mean
everybody says you know people learn
everything
from tv kids know every star every show
every plot and say why do they know that
junk when they can't memorize the
sequence of u.s
presidents well make a good enough
tv show about it and they probably will
not that i'm a fan of tv but i am a fan
of the visual image and i think tv
betrays it
to some sort to some degree hdtv
may correct that but it gives
psychedelics an interesting role because
they
are such stimulants to the visual
imagination it's almost like they lead
us
deeper in this cultural direction that
we have
great appetite for and now you know with
cd-rom and multi-media
and websites and all that we just can't
wait
to show each other stuff everybody's
building a website
everybody wants to invite you over to
see their their
latest visual creation
and i think that language itself
is headed in this direction that our
language is
literally becoming more colorful more
sparkling
more engaging and it's because it's
becoming more
visual and eventually it may be an
entirely
visual exercise the rise of icons
is an interesting example of this but
now wherever you go
in the world if you will push yourself
just a little bit
you can understand what's going on
because signage is so
iconographic it doesn't matter whether
you're in germany or france or
argentina or where you are the signage
is an
is in an international language of
visible
symbols that unite assault you see the
thing is the word is ambiguous
to a far greater degree than the image
and so when we
communicate in words we communicate
incompletely if we communicate in images
it's much closer to
fulfilling the intent of communication
which is to erase the boundaries
between the messenger and those the
messages being sent to
the thing that mcluhan was trying to say
was
that every medium
be it print even treated the electric
light
as a medium every medium has
a hidden agenda which you're not
the users of the medium are not aware of
until it's
too late for instance in his discussion
of the automobile
it was invented to convey people from
place to place
in practical terms what it was was a
bedroom away from home
and a whole generation of people
discovered sexuality
much earlier than they would have
because of the automobile
that wasn't its intent but that was its
effect
similarly mcluhan says you could never
have the concept of the citizens
if you if it was not preceded by the
invention of movable type
because the citizen is an
interchangeable
social unit the way a ladder is an
interchangeable unit
in topography also the linearity of
western thought
is a product of the fact that when we
communicate and print we arrange our
thoughts
in line that isn't done in some in some
languages but in ours it is well then we
impeach that
quality of our communication method
to uh reality itself
my hope is that through holography
and virtual reality and hdtv
and a deep awareness of mcluhan
that we could create what i would call a
biaseless
media in other words it would be a media
that would do to you exactly what
reality does
to you instead of pushing you in some
other direction
and it would be then a return to the
archaic
and it might be technically very
sophisticated
but the final impression must be i am
not looking at a screen
i am not turning the pages of a book i
am not listening to earphones
i am really having this experience and
it is
really real i've never heard the vr
process talk about it as
a bias-less form of media but i think
that's
what we're headed for well when media
becomes biaseless
media becomes reality
[Music]
you